how do everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry fear okay
I've been put in a trap obviously and
some bad stuffs about happen I've just
noticed too that his fingernails are
getting a little bloody so nice that
they're showing some detail and getting
some wear and tear but okay let's
trigger the trap okay still suspicious
anyone just know just he's gonna have
good thing I got long get to the gun
reload
oh why did I get rid of all my melee
weapons why why what what is my a button
not work okay we're back okay
Oh screw y'all happy baby I don't even
know what I need this diffuse that was a
long time ago you know
[Music]
switching to the shotgun okay yeah I
know exactly where to go
I'll run and get it out that's just
disappointing disappointing with myself
I guess because I fumbled my keys I
turned off my phone I didn't see a thing
[Music]
so got that Oh their thing beyond my
merry way
[Music]
I haven't care actually I should
probably cuz it's dark I need to reload
this ball club I don't care if I'm
wasting bullets use a screwdriver I'm
ready for you no no f you
those out here what the hell are you
kidding me where's my gun I you bastard
oh you sue oh no I'm just getting out of
you screw you guys
up - but oh I'll take one of these
chairs shove it up your butt probably
get out of here good no don't no no
thank you sir or madam I can tell let's
get it out of here
gee I've got too much crap hey screw
this sniper rifle so I hate this
inventory so see Astrid I gotta go back
alright okay hello peeps how's it going
everywhere why did I give Oh Oh screw
this shotgun I know where you are
oh it's dark but I don't care well I
guess you guys can't see anything so
I'll reload this aren't you stay in the
dark oh yeah me a reelin Ariel that bug
again
reloading again wasting one moment
that's not all right unless the door
says lock this obviously
doors locking we go okay and we're in
yay why okay
oh why I reloaded you son of a monkey
I was yeah you stay there it's that bug
again quickly after I go whatever noise
chairs are helping me what I just got
out of there exit nope
looking for a fiery exit
I do notice sometimes when I replay
sections because you know but if I
replay a section all I'll not be talking
over and I can actually hear the music
and like that chainsaw guy he's Piazza
fire baby ah oh yeah I'm so great
alright back outside gentlemen that
place so cool that it their boss is far
I could use a drink
feel bad okay I got the fuse I go back
to inhale
I got hurt
nope didn't hurt all right who wants
some bullets sausage shotgun cuz I got
plenty of that
I don't fault the game for any of my
death Hey all of my desks were pretty
much my own fault I don't fault the game
the game is still very very good I need
a safe oh I missed a safe point back
there let's hope I don't die let me
shoot me so oh that oh no chainsaw man
Jegs aw man
[Music]
shared care guys
I'm not scared
huh yes
braveness juice
don't man don't bro bro bro ah yeah
these guys messing with case you didn't
know they're messing with me
like this
[Music]
who's out there
okay got to fuse all the fuses for the
subway that wasn't
okay
actually I gotta cut it here thank you
guys so much for watching as always I
appreciate everything you wanna do and I
will see you in the next part
markiplier out